today's episode of the y-files is
brought to you by established titles
[Music]
in September 1994 Yitzhak Rabin prime
minister of Israel received an ominous
message it was a warning that his life
was in danger the center of the message
said this information was secretly
encoded in the Bible we're being ignored
the warning a year later the Prime
Minister was assassinated the code
hidden within the Bible not only
predicted rabin's assassination but also
predicted the date and even the name of
the killer secretly encoded in the Bible
written thousands of years ago are
predictions of every major world event
including terrifying events yet to come
abrahamic religions are those that
worship the god of Abraham and these
include Christianity Islam and Judaism
and this is more than half the world's
population over 4 billion people and
since the dawn of these religions
Believers have tried to derive meaning
from religious texts usually it's
through deciphering symbolism and
allegory but computer scientists
statisticians and mathematicians have
found literal information encoded in the
Old Testament the Old Testament written
between two and three thousand years ago
is based on the 24 books of the Hebrew
Bible and despite being one of the
oldest texts in the world it's remained
unchanged in all that time when scribes
made copies of the Old Testament if they
made even a single error that entire
text had to be buried why was accuracy
so important most would say it's because
this is the word of God and to alter his
word would be blasphemy but there may be
a more technical reason for maintaining
accuracy that God or someone encoded
Secrets within the texts in the late
13th century Rabbi Bahia Ben Asher found
a code hidden in the Book of Genesis he
read four letters skipped 42 letters
read another four letters and so on and
when his chosen letters were strung
together they created a new passage that
described the creation of the moon this
phrase also said that the lunar month is
precisely
29.53 days now that's a significant
finding because the exact length of the
lunar month wasn't calculated until 1996
by NASA Rabbi Ben Asher's work was
Revisited in the 1940s by Rabbi hmd Vice
Mandel and vice Mandel called this type
of code an equidistant letter sequence
or Els otherwise known as a skip code
how it works is you take a letter or
number of letters then you skip a
certain number of letters then you take
your same number of letters skip the
same number and repeat Rabbi Ben Asher
skipped 42 letters but you could use any
number then you link your letters
together to form new words now in the
1940s this was difficult to do manually
but later using computers finding skip
codes would become incredibly easy
computer programs could also expand on
the skip code technique using more
complicated search parameters originally
letters found in skip codes would be
strung together to form one long line of
text but computers allowed researchers
to take these long strings and divide
them into lines and these lines could be
20 characters long or 50 or whatever you
put into the program now with letters
arranged on a grid new messages could be
found by searching for text horizontally
vertically and diagonally kind of like
solving a word search puzzle so using
this technique mathematicians Elijah
rips door and whitsum and you'll have
Rosenberg performed a series of
experiments in 1985 called the Great
rabbis experiment rips and his
colleagues made a list of 34 famous
rabbis and sages from the Encyclopedia
of Great Men in Israel they input the
names of the rabbis into their program
to see if they were referenced in code
in the Bible well did the program find
the rabbis even though these 34 men men
were born and died hundreds or even
thousands of years after the Bible was
written their names were encoded in the
Bible every single one
[Music]
doctors rips Whitson and Rosenberg took
the names of famous rabbis and input
them into their computer program the
program was then instructed to iterate
through various skip codes and grid
sizes searching for the names once a
match was found the program would then
search horizontally vertically and
diagonally for dates that intersected
the names these dates would then be
compared to the known dates of birth and
death for each of the names the results
of the experiment surprised everyone the
computer program found all the names of
the rabbis encoded within the Bible and
when arranged on a grid they also found
the dates of birth and death
intersecting the names they tried again
with 32 more names again the program
worked all the names and dates were
encoded in the Bible to be sure they
tested their program on the novel War
and Peace and other long religious texts
they found nothing only random letters
but in the Bible the names were there in
total they found the names of 166 men
encoded in the Bible thousands of years
before any of the them were born Dr Ripp
said the odds of this happening by
chance was about 1 in 10 million the
only conclusion that could be drawn from
the scientific research regarding the
Torah codes is that they exist and that
they are not a mere coincidence doctors
rips Whitson and Rosenberg published the
results of their study in the
peer-reviewed journal statistical
science naturally the study was
controversial several experts tried to
find a mistake but nobody could in 1997
Harold Gans a senior cryptologic
mathematician for the NSA set out to
disprove the Bible Code when Gans first
heard the story he wasn't just skeptical
he said it was nonsense people are
always coming up with all kinds of weird
claims the Loch Ness monster bigfoot
flying saucers by nature and by training
I'm a skeptical person one day my wife
asked if I had ever heard of something
called Torah codes I said yes but she
shouldn't take it seriously she asked
how do you know had you looked into it I
distinctly remember saying I've better
things to do with my time and chase
after nonsense and she said how do you
know it's nonsense Gans created his own
computer program to disprove the Bible
Code Not only was he able to find the
names of the rabbis and their birth and
death dates in the Bible his program
also found their places of birth and
death so another skeptic term believer
in 1990 Dr rips had an idea he was able
to find information about rabbis who
lived hundreds of years ago but he
wondered if the Bible also had
information about people who were still
alive in 1990 Saddam Hussein was one of
the most famous people on the planet Dr
rips input the dictator's name into the
program to see if he was encoded in the
Bible was he he was
and if the Bible Code was correct Saddam
Hussein was going to attack Israel in
three weeks
he sure did
no it's amazing
and only in the Bible do you find this
when for instance by skipping an equal
number of letters you spell out
President Kennedy
the very next letters in the same skip
sequence say to die and Dallas is
encoded in the same place
when you look for Shakespeare the very
next words in the same equal distance
skip sequence say We'll present plays on
stage and Hamlet Macbeth are encoded in
the same place when Dr rips input the
name Saddam Hussein into his Bible Code
program the name was found also
intersecting Saddam Hussein's name were
the phrases Russian missile and fire on
third Shabbat on January 18 1990 the
third Shabbat of the Hebrew calendar
Iraq fired a russian-made missile into
Israel sparking the Gulf War this had Dr
rips wondering if other major events
were coded in the Bible it turned out
that many were in 1992 Michael drosnan
an American investigative journalist was
in Israel working on a story about war
in the Middle East while there he was
told about Dr Rip's work Michael drosnan
didn't believe in God much less that God
would be putting coded messages in the
Bible but it sounded like an interesting
story droznan originally set aside an
hour to speak with Dr ribs but before
the hour is over drozen extended his
stay in Israel rip show draws them that
it was possible that the Bible contained
billions of messages
droznan intrigued but skeptical tried to
debunk the theory he couldn't instead he
worked with rips to see what other
messages could be decoded and over the
next few years droznan and rips found
over 1 000 events encoded in the text of
the Old Testament they looked at the
Book of Genesis where God tells Abraham
look now toward heaven and count the
Stars encoded In this passage is the
date July 20th 1969 and the word
spaceship and Apollo 11. the phrase
economic crisis is found once it's
intersected with the words depression
and stocks in the year 1929. the word
Oklahoma crosses the word mura which was
the building destroyed in the Oklahoma
City bombing intersecting those words is
the phrase his name was Timothy in May
1994 the Shoemaker Levy Comet was all
over the news scientists were
speculating whether or not it would
trash into Jupiter droznan searched the
Bible Code and found the answer the
exact name Schumacher Levy is there it
intersects with the phrase will pound
Jupiter crossing the phrase is the date
July 16 1994 the correct date of impact
that same year drozden searched the name
of Israel's prime minister Yitzhak Rabin
rabin's name was there crossed by the
phrase assassin will assassinate and the
Hebrew date 57 56 which was a few months
away in the Hebrew language numbers also
have word meanings
5756 could be interpreted as will you
change it droznan felt this was a sign
that he should try to stop this
prediction from coming true he sent a
message to the Prime Minister Rabin
didn't listen and was dead a year later
just as the Bible Code predicted on
January 26 1996 drosnan and Dr rips
found another ominous prediction the
word Libya intersected the phrase Atomic
Holocaust if predictions couldn't be
changed this did not bode well for
Israel or the world because the date
that crossed Libya and atomic Holocaust
was January 27 1996.
tomorrow
[Music]
the Bible code contained the phrase
Atomic Holocaust crossed with the word
Libya and the date January 27 1996. that
day Muammar Gaddafi Libya's leader made
a public statement that Arab countries
threatened by Israel have a right to
nuclear weapons Michael drosnan feared
that this was the beginning of nuclear
war but fortunately the prediction
served more as a warning than as an
actual war after the prediction about
the assassination of prime minister
Yitzhak Rabin the Israeli government
took Bible Code predictions seriously
they did this quietly and with
skepticism but they still listened
drozen speculated that Israel may have
been working behind the scenes to
prevent nuclear war with Libya using the
Bible Code as a potential source of
intelligence something they would never
publicly admit as the months passed more
Bible Code predictions came true
Benjamin Netanyahu was predicted to lose
the 1996 prime minister election to
Shimon Perez the Bible Code said
otherwise and indeed Netanyahu won a
very close election by less than one
percent of the vote Lady Diana was
killed in a terrible car crash in Paris
in 1997. the Bible Code has a lot of
details about this the words princess
and Diana are encoded at the same skip
code distance next to this is the word
Spencer which was her maiden name
intersecting Spencer the word whales in
surrounding verses are the words Paris
and France tunnel and river and you
might remember she was killed in a
tunnel near The Sun Also encoded is the
date of 5757 which is the Hebrew date of
August 1997 the month and year she was
killed the name Fayed was found Dodi
Fayed was Diana's companion who also
died in the crash and later researchers
found the name Anri Henry Paul was the
driver of her car in 1997 Michael
drosnan released the book The Bible Code
which became an instant bestseller his
book inspired many other books about the
hidden messages encoded in the Old
Testament codes hidden within the Bible
predicted the fall of Saddam Hussein
insane the capture of Osama bin Laden
both Gulf Wars codes were found that saw
the 2008 financial crisis the swine flu
outbreak and natural disasters like
earthquakes tsunamis and hurricanes but
these were events that happened in the
past interpreting past events using the
Bible Code was easier than predicting
the future when an event has already
happened you have all the context if the
word Hiroshima is crossed with the
phrases fire from the heavens and
blisters and boils it's easy to see that
this refers to an atomic bomb and
radiation sickness predicting the future
isn't so easy without context what would
blisters and boils even mean you'd be
guessing the meaning of the phrases not
very scientific but the Bible Code
predicts terrible future disasters and
drozen felt that if he could locate a
key to decipher all the Bible's
predictions these disasters could be
prevented finally drosnan found the key
a stone pillar or Obelisk and according
to the Bible Code it was buried in
Jordan near the Red Sea so Michael
drosnan asked the Jordanian government
for permission to excavate the area to
his surprise permission was granted
logic tells me that the Bible was
encoded to give us very important
information it was encoded certainly by
some intelligence that could see ahead
across time
it was encoded in such a way that it
would be found right now
by technology that would exist for the
first time now
the computer in 2002 Michael drosnan
believed that the Bible held a hidden
code that predicted an impending nuclear
war he found references to the city's
Jerusalem and New York intersecting the
name Bin Laden in the year 2006. drosnan
contacted the Israeli and United States
governments but they ignored his
warnings allegedly allegedly even though
nuclear war didn't happen in 2006
drosnan still felt there was imminent
danger and was worried he got the date
wrong drosnan believed there was a key
to the entire Bible Code in the form of
a stone Obelisk hidden somewhere in the
Jordanian desert and if this Obelisk was
discovered it would allow all
predictions in the Old Testament to be
deciphered averting the coming
apocalypse but who put the obelisk in
the desert in the first place and why
drosnan wasn't religious he didn't
believe it was God speaking to Moses on
the top of Mount Sinai drosnan actually
believed that Moses was speaking to
please see aliens please see aliens
aliens
games it's aliens because the Bible Code
could be deciphered with a computer
drazden believed the only way to create
the code was with a computer an
incredibly Advanced Computer the theory
was that given enough data an extremely
Advanced computer program could
successfully predict all the events of
the future just like a computer that's
used to predict highway traffic patterns
where the weather you put in as much
data as you can and then the computer
can predict with reasonable accuracy how
fast cars are going to be moving on a
freeway or if it's going to rain if the
aliens use computer programs that
operated at the quantum level they could
predict any possible outcome when the
Jordanian government approved the
excavation request drosnan brought in
experts from all over the world
archaeologists geologists and
researchers of all kinds were flown in
finally the Obelisk would be discovered
and every code hidden within the Old
Testament would be unlocked what did
they find well the political climate of
the Middle East shifts quickly at the
last minute the excavator Invasion
permit was revoked
Michael drosnan would go on to publish
two more books about the Bible Code but
as the years went on and fewer
predictions came true each new book
performed worse than the previous one in
June 2020 Michael drosnan passed away
after spending 25 years researching even
learning Hebrew in the process Michael
drozden wouldn't live to see the Bible
Code proved the proof is allegedly still
buried in the desert and to find it
would take nothing short of a miracle
and until we get that Miracle we'll have
to settle for science
the Bible Code does not give us one
predetermined future it tells us all of
our possible Futures and by having this
information in advance
we can prevent the worst dangers from
ever taking place when Michael drosnan
released his first book The Bible Code I
was fascinated with it whether the Bible
was created by time traveling humans
from the future aliens from another
world or God himself draws didn't seemed
to answer questions that we all have are
we alone or is there something more an
intelligence beyond our understanding if
the research into Bible codes was
considered Fringe then Michael drosnan
was considered On The Fringe Of The
Fringe drozden built on the work of Dr
eliu rips who first published his paper
on the Bible codes in 1985 but Professor
rips didn't believe drosnan's
predictions he felt that drozden was
only seeing what he wanted to see and
would manipulate and interpret the
results of the computer program to
support the predictions but to be fair
Dr rips still believe that the original
study the great rabbi's experiment was
true that the names and dates of the
great Hebrew sages were coded in the
Bible however Dr ripp's work had
challengers in 1999 Australian
mathematician Brendan McKay published
his own paper in statistical science the
same Journal that published Dr ribs Dr
McKay pointed out that Rip's methodology
was deeply flawed for example in Dr
Rip's study if the month and day were
correct but the year was wrong that was
still counted as a match if the year is
correct but the month was wrong that was
also a match plus Dr rips allowed name
matches that were very vague nicknames
titles and initials were all counted as
matches for example if you were
searching for matches about Elvis E A
Presley or Mr Presley or EAP would all
be considered matches so would husband
of Priscilla or Lisa Marie's father or
even the king also while modern Hebrew
uses vowels the ancient written Hebrew
language did not so word matches were
found using only consonants which gave
the researchers a lot of wiggle room
both Dr rips and Michael drosnan blew
off this criticism in fact droslin said
if my critics can find a message about
the assassination of a prime minister in
Moby Dick maybe I'll believe him no way
that was in Moby Dick oh Not only was
the assassination of Yitzhak Rabin and
Moby Dick McKay showed that it was there
multiple times yet it was only found
once in the Old Testament McKay also
showed that the death of Lady die was in
Moby Dick so were references to the
assassination of Robert Kennedy as well
as other famous events
aliens wrote the Bible and Moby Dick did
they ever consider that they probably
didn't McKay's point was if you already
know the outcome you want and you have a
long enough text with enough letters you
can manipulate a computer program to
churn through any text in order to give
you the result that you want McKay even
used this technique to find phrases
about the September 11th attack in song
lyrics by Vanilla Ice all right stop
what collaborate enlist in ice is back
with my brand new invention
I can't believe I fell for that oh leave
it every time another problem is that
although the text of the Old Testament
is almost identical to the text from two
or three thousand years ago it's not a
perfect match comparisons of the current
text to older copies like the Dead Sea
Scrolls show a discrepancy of a few
characters a human reader wouldn't
notice a difference but a computer
program designed to create a message by
skipping a certain number of characters
that would break the program so are
there messages hidden within the text of
the Bible or is this yet another case of
the human mind trying to form patterns
in Randomness trying to make order from
chaos
I don't know I do know that there are
things in the universe beyond our
understanding and as long as Mysteries
exist we have a duty to try and solve
them in other words it is the glory of
God to conceal a matter and it is the
honor of Kings to search it out so I
guess we keep searching
[Music]
today's episode is brought to you by one
of the most unique sponsors we've ever
had established titles and that doesn't
sound like VPN stuff where it's not huh
my change of pace established titles let
you buy as little as one square foot of
land in Scotland and this allows you to
call yourself Lord or Laird as they say
or lady also established titles plants a
tree with every order and is partnered
with great Charities like one tree
planted
hold on what did you just say I could
buy land in Scotland and become a lord
yep you can even use the title on your
credit cards plane tickets online dating
profile yep so I want it well there's
more I want to tell you about this I
want it now Lord hecklefish commands you
fine
[Music]
my package
you're kidding me right
what is this
um what is this my Lord if you don't
mind yeah you might be taking this a
little bit amazing okay okay hang on I
could get used to this
okay this certifies you as Lord
hecklefish Moriarty and uh this is the
plot Number of your land in Edelson
Scotland and uh they even sent us
coordinates Google Map it that May
survey my domain
s it is
half day to work the land for me and pay
me tribute uh you can't have any serves
I shall be a straight great but fair
Lord of these lands my serfs will come
to idolize me you can't have serfs I
could maybe have a few safes you can't
one surf no stop saying surfs stop
saying surfs my Lord all right but check
this out the first 200 people who
purchased a title pack using the promo
code twf will get land right near yours
Kinda Yeah
I strict but fair Lord to all who
purchase using promo code twf well you
won't be there Lord there'll be Lords
and Ladies of their own land not for now
but when they raise an Army in coconut
land I shall rule over them and they
will come to know me as a strict but
fair Lord you can't conquer their land
there may be a marriage pact to
strengthen the kingdom I don't see how
that shall be truth my eldest son to the
daughter of one of the other Lords we
will unite our kingdoms and my blood
shall rule these lands for a thousand
years you have an eldest son but what do
you think those guppy support payments
are for Heckle Jr lives with his mother
in Hackensack New Jersey if you use code
twf you'll get an additional 10 off so
go to establishtitles.com twf you'll be
Lord of your own land you'll get your
own plot number and you get this cool
frame certificate this makes an amazing
last minute gift plus you'll be
supporting a great charity and helping
out the channel and you'll be joining my
kingdom right and that you will come to
know me as a strict
yeah we got it feel before me get bent
it don't make me declare Prima nocta ugh
gross
[Laughter]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the white files if you had
fun or learned anything do me a favor
and like subscribe comment and share
that stuff really helps the channel and
like most topics we cover on this
channel today's topic was recommended by
you and if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips and special thanks to
our patrons who make this channel
possible I'm amazed by your generosity
and I couldn't do this without you if
you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon or
grabbing something from the Wi-Fi store
well that's gonna do it until next time
be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
something grabs a hold of me tightly
flows like a harpoon daily and nightly
yo I don't know turn off the lights and
I'll glow to the extreme I rock a bike
like a fan to light up a stage and watch
a Chomp like a candle games gorgeous
speak of the boobs I'm killing your
brain like a voice